foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everyone
that's it
come on man we're up here we're up here
exposing our hearts and Minds to the
world let's try that again good
afternoon everyone
there we go
we are here to talk about building AI
quickly collaboratively and with
confidence using collab on vertex AI
I think I'm supposed to introduce us now
okay so I am nenshad bartoliwala I work
for the Department of Motor Vehicles in
the state of California
but uh it's just a reference of the
keynote yesterday but uh I my day job is
I actually run the product management
team for the vertex ml platform and I am
joined by my esteemed colleague who is
very humble but he's one of the ogs of
the vertex team he's been on this for
what five years yeah five years so
before when vertex was just a little
baby
Karthik was the daddy
hi I'm I'm chandan I'm a nunchucks team
I'm a group product manager and I'm a
I'm going to talk about collab
Enterprise today so ask if you guys like
the product tell me uh if you don't like
the product also tell me but preferably
not too loudly
because I'll hear it
I will hear it okay
okay so let's do a product introduction
and overview that'll be me then I'll
turn it over to Karthik and he'll walk
you through uh some of the details okay
so what is collab Enterprise first of
all let's get a show of hands how many
of you actually use collab uh in your
day-to-day work
fantastic so uh that's going to remain
an amazing product available for uh
consumers but we now have an Enterprise
version okay and so it has all the
capabilities of what you see in collab
uh today but it also brings all the
Enterprise level security capabilities
compliance support repeatability Etc
that you need if you want to run this at
scale in your business okay
so history of collab it launched in
November of 2017.
uh what then happened is by November of
2019 it got to 1 million users that is
not easy to do for any product but
collab just took off people got very
excited by it uh Alpha fold launched on
collab in July of 2021
and uh in June of 2023 we added some
really cool features I don't know how
many of you have used it yet but we're
kind of into this whole code assistance
thing uh hopefully you heard about duet
yesterday as well as our Kodi models and
so AI code assistance made its way into
uh collab the consumer version of collab
and uh then we introduced a really cool
feature in July called Auto charting you
actually can take a data frame and ask
the system to go and generate the right
type of chart and the system will kind
of automatically do that for you uh just
a small note but in the preview actually
every time you submitted that Karthik
would draw the diagram for you in the
background now the software actually
does it and here we are in August of
2023 and uh collab is now ready as an
Enterprise product it's ready for all of
you to start using today and we're
really excited for you to start taking
advantage of some of its capabilities
now one of the great things about
working in Google cloud is that we have
access to some of the most amazing
research uh from our Google Deep Mind
and research teams and one of the cool
things that we get to do as product
managers here uh in a dis in addition to
giving demos about the Department of
Motor Vehicles is that we actually get
to take research that comes out of our
research team and productize that and I
think you've seen some pretty amazing
examples uh
we started this journey with something
named after one of the founders uh kids
elephant how many of you remember Hadoop
remember when that was The Craze yeah
yeah I still have the t-shirts my wife
won't let me wear them anymore they're
too old but I still have them so we
started our journey in 2003 actually
taking Hadoop
we took some of that technology and of
course commercialized it but we also
always have a parallel path for taking
things and bringing them uh into the
open source world and so I think the
first set of libraries that really
started to democratize uh and bring uh
to a broad Market neural networks was
actually tensorflow how many of you have
actually coded against tensorflow people
good awesome and so uh you know we
brought tensorflow to the market we've
brought kubernetes to the market and
these were all technologies that were
used inside of Google but then we
decided to make to you know available to
a broader audience but we also tried to
provide these capabilities directly in
the cloud so you can see examples are
automl product for example
well is one that came out of Google
research and then we productized uh Nas
neural architecture search uh it is not
the rapper Nas he is not part of our
roadmap but neural architecture search
uh became a product in the Google
portfolio is still available today and
then you see more recent capabilities in
fact uh how many of you know that
Transformers the technology behind all
this channel AI stuff actually was
developed at Google in 2017. yes thank
you for raising your hands diffusion
models so if you've seen things like
stable diffusion who invented that
technology Google Google research and
now you know given where we are in 2023
we have this amazing partnership with
Google research and Google Cloud where
we can take capabilities like those
models and like collab which was
actually built by Google research and
bring it to all of you in an Enterprise
context so we work really really closely
together and it's fun
so one of the big things that all of you
told us is that uh you wanted to be able
to use these type of notebook
environments across multiple Google
products and confession we haven't
always been great about that okay we're
not perfect but we do try to listen to
your feedback and get better
so with colab Enterprise how many of you
heard the announcement yesterday about
bigquery Studio
remember hearing that yeah
so the colab Enterprise and bigquery
studio is the exact same collab
Enterprise in vertex so those of you who
want to do things like uh build your uh
build your data sets and do feature
engineering using bigquery data and
using big frames and some of that
technology you could do that in colab
now you have your data set and you want
to start doing some uh you know plotting
or statistics descriptive statistics on
top of that you could do that in colab
you decide you want to train a model and
now you want to do that in Vertex or you
can use bqml you could do that in colab
and then deploy of course these models
from collab so it's a single environment
that spans the entire data to AI Journey
which makes things a lot easier than
having to go through four or five
different tools to get one job done for
one uh one Persona or type of user
okay is let's get let's get started is
that the cue for you to do your dance
yeah that's that's the demo Let's uh
let's go ahead and switch over to the
demo machine
and let's not let that play because we
don't want to do that
okay great
um so uh first of all ninja just
mentioned collab Enterprise is available
both through vertex and through bigquery
Studio I'm going to go ahead and bring
it up in vertex right now
so
um what happens when it pops up is you
can see that there are two distinct
panels on the screen on the left hand
side is a no managed notebook storage
and on the right hand side is where the
editor will pop up I'm going to go ahead
and create a new notebook what this does
behind the scenes is it creates a
managed ipy and B file it's industry
standard ip1d you can upload your
existing notebooks to the servers and
everything should just kind of work
um
and it does it in the region U.S Central
one that I've specified now I uh I'm
stopping on this phone and just kind of
talking about it a little bit because if
you use collab today you'll notice that
it's a drive-based product one of the
things we did when we brought this
product to cloud is we introduce manage
notebook storage that is compliant with
all of gcp security capabilities and
compliances so you'll find that the
notebook storage does behave a little
bit differently but it's very much on
track to be feature
at Future parity between the two
offerings now the next thing I did is I
actually just executed this first code
cell in the notebook and what happened
here is that the notebook connected to a
runtime a virtual machine that's running
in the same region and it's private to
this user me and it executed the code
that's there
this is actually using the default
runtime which is an N2 standard two it's
a fully managed short-lived VM that we
allocate as you start executing code
just so you don't have to do any
configuration to get started you just
hit play you get the compute you need it
runs wait the Karthik I use these
products every day I have to set up
networking and vpcsc I have to yodel at
a certain volume in order to get this
all set up did you just tell me that I
could open this and just get started
right away
what a wonderful prompt uh yes you
absolutely can and we also understand
that people have needs where they want
maybe larger machines they want
different machines they want access to
the full power of all the accelerators
available on gcp they may need to
configure networking or organizational
policies we have another mechanism in
the product that I'll show you in a
second for doing this but for right now
let's just hang out with a friend the
default runtime
and I'm going to go ahead and start the
demo talking about the thing that
absolutely nobody else is talking about
which is uh code generation and
generative AI I'm sure you haven't heard
mention of it yet
um but the product actually comes with
two code gen features um code complete
and code gen code complete you can just
start typing in stuff and as it figures
out what you're typing in it should be
able to do things like give you that
suggestion kerasload model I don't
actually like that one so maybe I'll do
model equals
sequence and hopefully it'll some point
figure out that I'm trying to do
sequences as you notice this code
Generation stuff will get better as you
type in more code into the notebook
it'll use the entirety of the context
that you provide in the notebook to
generate code it'll likewise do the same
thing with the code generation feature
so I'm going to go ahead and do that and
I'm going to click create
and I want to say hey can you give me
some Pi torch code for classifying
an image
an amnest data set
and it helps if you can type and not
make too many errors
oh sorry I actually want to hit the
generate button there it goes so
what have we here we have Pi touch code
that loads the mnis data set from
torchism and trains
a model
in addition to the code you get the
recitation the set of sources that were
actually important in gendering this
code now I'm a long time googler as
nunchod mentioned so I'm not as big a
fan of Pi torches some people and I kind
of prefer Keras so let me go over and do
that
great it also gave me Keras code for
training data based on the mnist data
set but Karthik is this just a stock
example no it actually isn't and this is
actually really nerve-wracking to be up
here right now because this could have
done something else and given you a
slightly different core sample this one
actually looks like it will run in about
a few seconds I'm actually going to hit
play and see if it does and uh well for
the sake of the demo I really hope it
does but before I do that
let me show you one other cool thing and
I can just kind of say
summarize the above code
in bullet points
again my spelling skills do need some
work
but
it gives you a nice little summary of
the code but you could then maybe go in
and drop in as a
um
as a comment into this anyways I like
that I like that particular trick it's
it's pretty useful again if you put in
build up your notebook and start adding
more stuff the code completion the code
generation is going to get smarter it's
going to give you more useful and more
relevant results because the entire
context that you provide in the notebook
is being used to inform those those
recommendations
now comes the fun part for you maybe
lesser for me and I'm going to actually
hit the play button and we're going to
see what happens here
so so far so good it's actually
downloading and running this code and
now it's actually turning a model
I want to take a moment while this is
happening to talk about compute again so
right now this is running on the N2
standard form machine that is a default
machine for this notebook
this is a deep learning model it's not
the deepest learning model you could
come up with but it is deep learning and
it will probably benefit from having a
GPU
available to it
now we have
um one of the big and powerful features
of collab Enterprise is the ability to
access all of the gpus that are
available on Google cloud and the way
you can do that is through the runtime
templates feature
I'm going to actually stop that and go
ahead and flip over to the runtime
templates
so
creating uh accessing more powerful
compute on collab Enterprise is a
two-step process first step is an
administrator creates a runtime template
second step is to use the instantiates a
runtime based on that template I'm going
to step back and give you just a little
bit of context around why we decided to
set this up this way on the one hand we
know that many users are going to want a
lot of a lot more powerful compute than
it's on the standard but at the same
time What folks who run data science
teams run platform teams tell us is they
want some control over the types of
resources that uses spin up in the
Regency spin up they want to be able to
set certain configurations maybe they
need to run them on certain vpcs and
maybe they need to disable external IPS
things like that this is where runtime
templates comes in the idea is we want
to give you as an administrator the
ability to control the type of compute
that you use has used while still giving
your users as much flexibility as
possible uh to be able to spin up what
they need when they need it
so the process for creating a template
is pretty simple you click new template
you go ahead and run to this t-step
process for example let's say I want to
do a deep learning runtime template
I've been executing everything in U.S
Central once I'll keep it in that region
you could eventually add labels other
types of metadata to this
you can then pick the machine you can if
you want to give your users access to
say a100 you have the full A2 Line If
you're looking for L4 if you have the G2
line there in this case I'm going to go
ahead and pick something like an N1 high
mem16 and that lets me attach an Nvidia
Tesla T4 or a V100
the next step is I can specify some
networking and security configurations
here as well
I've already created a template that
fulfills this basic format deep learning
templates with GeForce
now once you as an administer have done
that you use this when they actually
want to use it
can go ahead and go back to the notebook
I'm going to go ahead and make that full
screen and click on this connect to a
runtime button up here
now you get two options here you get to
create a new runtime and you can do it
from a template
uh and what will happen is we'll spin up
the machine if you specified it for the
user to use that machine will be private
to that user
or
you can connect to an existing runtime
I've actually already got a um a runtime
made from that particular
template spun up so I'm going to go
ahead and use that right now
and we're going to go ahead and connect
to it
we're now connected to that and I'm
going to rerun this code
but then I'm going to show you that I'm
actually now running this on a machine
that has a
T4 GPU attached to it I want to open up
the built-in terminal
and you'll see that we have
in we have all the Nvidia tools
installed on the runtime for your users
to work with I'm going to run Nvidia SMI
that's going to show you that I have a
T4 running and that is now currently
being utilized at 17 percent
by this model that's being trained here
and
um
there it goes now
while that's running I'm going to go
ahead and talk a little bit about
collaboration so I'm really happy with
this notebook I think it's great
um I want to of course share with my
boss and then shot so that he can tell
me how wonderful I am uh which is that's
what you will normally do is just you
know sing my praises and anyways is that
the right talk
so you can go to the notebook browser
you can click on share
and we actually enable sharing via I am
permissions so this is the standard
sharing mechanism across Google cloud
and standard permissioning mechanism
across Google Cloud uh all you have to
do is Click Share you can go ahead and
say Hey I want to share this with
nenshard
there he is and I can give him I
actually want to give him code editor
access
and
there you go he now has code editor
access to this notebook he can come in
he can run it he can do whatever he
wants
likewise when somebody shares a notebook
with me I'll see it under this shared
with me tab in the notebook editor again
everything is regionalized one of the
core foundations of how we've designed
collab Enterprise is to really respect
regionalization that is something I know
that's really important for a lot of
folks
um here
now in addition to sharing the other fun
feature that we have is we actually also
have built-in versioning so the system
every few minutes will go ahead and save
a snapshot of the file provided there
are some changes that have been there
and you can of course compare the
current version to the prior versions
now because this is a notebook it's
sometimes not the most helpful thing if
to do this because you'll see the
outputs we thought of that and we allow
you to remove the output from the diff
so you can see just the portions that
are your code you can also of course
restore and revert to a prior revision
of this
so
let's go back and see how our model
training has actually hopefully wrapped
up while we were working through that
and it did it did finish up and we ended
up with the model that looks like it's
probably pretty good it's uh accuracy is
0.98 so you know this is this is awesome
I do want to just stop here and say
um you know
six or seven years ago training in a
data set for emness to this level of
accuracy was a research challenge right
let alone having the code to do that
written by AI that wasn't something that
was happening in now six seven eight
years ago
um so this is you know I know this is a
demo that people have probably seen
variants of a number of products but
it's still pretty spectacular how far
we've come
now that I've finished pontificating I'm
going to go ahead and talk a little bit
about how
collab Enterprises integrated with both
bigquery and vertex so what I wanted to
do here was I just wanted to run through
a very simple example with a very common
data sets the penguin status to show you
how we could very easily pull data from
bigquery use bqml to train a model have
that all integrated with vertex model
registry so you can kind of do
everything from a fairly small set of
apis so here I'm just using the stock BQ
client to go ahead and pull data from
the public data set if you listen to the
bigquery studio announcement you'll
notice also a new API coming out called
Big frames that lets you load this into
a bigquery native data frame
representation
now if you print out the data frame you
get that auto plot feature that nunchuck
was talking about there's actually two
parts to it the first is you can convert
the data frame to an interactive table
and then you can go ahead and
filter on any of the columns within it
um or you can just go ahead and click on
this Nifty button and the system will
use some some smarts to try and figure
out what the visualizations of this data
that are likely to be the most useful
for you are
and you can take all the codes that is
generated and put it into you can take
all the plots that have been generated
you get the code for them you can reuse
them and work with them if you want
now once that's done what I always
notice about this particular example is
these 2D distributions for those who are
familiar with the Penguins data set it's
the goal is to build a classifier you
give it a bunch of measurements around
individual penguins and you're supposed
to figure out hey what species of
penguin does this particular record
belong to and what this shows you is
that hey likely this Coleman length and
come in depth they're probably pretty
good predictors
and if I were building a model from
scratch that would be useful information
instead what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to run bqml in kind of
automl mode and then she had mentioned
automl a little while ago
here all I really have to do is I have
to tell bqml that I want to use the
logistic regression that predicts on the
column species and then register the
results of the vertex AI model registry
right now
it's a couple of seconds to run so I'm
just going to go ahead and pop over to
vertex AI model registry and show you
what it looks like once it's actually
done
so if I pop over to model registry
I have my Penguins lr6 logistic
regression six sixth attempt I should
say and
just before I jump too far actually
modern registry is kind of the central
repository for models and vertex and
bqml all the multi-10 bqml all the model
C10 vertex can make their way here and
from here you can do a bunch of stuff so
in this particular case
I could go ahead and create an
evaluation job I can deploy it it's
actually already got a live endpoint I
could create a batch prediction job I
can create
um everything's version so I can see
multiple versions of this
I want to go ahead and click on this
view in bqml and I'm going to use this
opportunity to show you two things first
of all I want to show you that the model
is also available via bigquery studio so
you see it right here and you can see
the training metrics you can see the
evaluation metrics
second thing that I wanted to point out
is
as nunchak said all the notebooks that
you work with in
vertex are also reflected here in
bigquery studio under the notebook
section and then the third thing I
really want to show you here is that I
talked about how these VMS use the end
users personal credentials for those who
have used notebook products on vertex
before or in gcp you know that in the
past we use service accounts as the
authentication mechanism and what that
meant is you couldn't keep track of the
user's activities from The Notebook into
our other services we now use send uses
credentials so if the user calls
bigquery from within the notebook they
will see
um that is traceable now they will it'll
run on their own credentials you'll see
their identity and so on
so with that said I'm going to flip it
back over to nunchat for a slider two
maybe we can switch back to the
um
thing okay actually let me take the next
slide here next two slides it's very
hurtful I'm sorry you just handed it to
me and now you're taking it back I'm
gonna take it back that's hurtful okay
I'm sorry about that I heard nunchucks
feelings that messed you up on my perf
we'll see
um anyways uh just as a quick review of
what we did we did a code completion
code generation autoplot
from the other key features we talked
about collaboration I am based notebook
sharing automatic versioning then we
talked about
um how we have zero config
compute option as well as a configurable
flexible compute option
and then we haven't talked a lot about
Enterprise horizontals but as we get the
product through a life cycle and get it
into GA and Beyond we'll be supporting a
kind of full set of gcp security
capabilities
now oh now I get it yes thank you
okay so I just want to walk through the
stack so that we understand where these
capabilities fit into the overall uh
vertex set of offerings
so the first part of course which is not
a direct part of vertex is the Google
Cloud infrastructure okay and of course
we depend on this very heavily we have
state-of-the-art capabilities with gpus
you saw Jensen Huang on on stage
yesterday but we also announced the new
version of our tpus
v5e I think if I got it correctly and we
continue to invest to make sure that we
provide the absolute best rock solid
Hardware that you can use for AI and
machine learning
the second layer of course is the model
garden and you would have seen that
yesterday as well and the idea for us is
that we're very proud of our first party
bottles the one that we've built
ourselves like palm and Cody and imagine
but the fact is that even at the scale
of Google we can't build everything
ourselves right and so uh We've we've
made our approach very open we provide a
ton of Open Source models you saw llama
and code llama yesterday but we also
have stable diffusion and many many
others that we provide inside of the
model Garden environment and the idea is
you should have the choice if you want
to use an open source model that allows
you to do what you want to do you should
you should be able to use it there's no
reason you have to use Google's models
then the AI platform is what
traditionally we've called this vertex
actually now vertex AI encompasses this
whole thing uh it's a it's a branding
shift but it's important to know
so the AI platform represents all the
capabilities around
being able to build and evaluate models
so that includes notebooks that includes
our training service that includes our
model evaluation services and the like
it includes all the services around
being able to what ml Engineers use to
put models into production so this is
things like
pipelines and our prediction service and
the feature store and and this
collection of capabilities and then of
course many of the pre-built apis that
we can use in order to be able to uh
solve specific use cases without having
to do a lot of configuration and one of
the things that that we're very proud of
is that we have built all of the
generative AI support in vertex directly
into the platform we haven't outsourced
it to somebody else
so you all the skills that you've built
on vertex already whether it's using our
notebooks or using our training service
or using our inference service
everything that you did for predictive
AI the generative AI stuff uses the
exact same platform it's all the
security the compliance the way we use
gpus and tpus is exactly the same and
that is not the same approach that some
of the other folks in the market have
taken okay
then we have two package package systems
that we provide one is search this is
Enterprise search so being able to
search on your data and being able to
ground the results how many of you have
heard this term hallucination
right yeah that's not just for Grateful
Dead concerts anymore it also happens
with these large models thank you
uh it's you know it's uh these models
actually will make things up and so
being able to ground your data uh and
and show empirically that the result
you're looking at on the screen is
actually uh derived from data that you
actually have in your Corpus is really
really important and that's where search
comes in and then of course conversation
uh everybody's is in chat bot land I
think you know everywhere you go you're
seeing people come up with new versions
and new iterations but these can be very
complex it's not just about information
seeking you can actually do entire
transactions inside of a chat interface
and so all of these build on top of each
other so actually the AI platform Powers
many of the large language model
capabilities in search Powers many of
the large language model capabilities
inside of conversation
then there are solutions some of you may
use in your businesses today these are
things like Doc AI which continues to
get new innovation or contact center AI
capabilities Etc but the key point I you
know I want to emphasize to everyone is
that you know vertex has become this
very very rich platform it's not just
the just the core infrastructural
capabilities but many of these higher
level services and uh colab integrates
really well with all of them so if you
choose to use collab because you want to
do in fact in the model Garden when you
click on fine tuning an open source
model it'll open up a collab notebook we
want all of these services to integrate
and work well together so that you can
get to productivity quickly it's not fun
having to stitch together a bunch of
services you know we we know that and so
we've we're trying to make it a lot
easier and make the entire vertex stack
which now includes search and
conversation these other areas work
really nicely and and help all of you
get to productivity quicker
I think it's back to you oh thank you um
so uh this slide is for those who are
already using vertex workbench and the
question we often get is how do we think
about the differences between workbench
and Jupiter lab
so you know workbench is built on
Jupiter lab in the C standard very
familiar to a lot of your users a lot of
data scientists and analysts live in
Jupiter lab today the product is very
flexible very customizable and again
it's open in the sense that it's built
on the open source version of Jupiter
lab so you can do a lot of customization
you can bring in extensions things like
that
it's a good choice for data scientists
who are already using Jupiter lab maybe
on their laptop and you'd like to
transition them onto the cloud
it's also good if you're working with
very complex projects where you have
things spanning multiple files maybe you
have shell scripts and Python scripts
and other things in there it's really
nice in that scenario and it's got a
really nice set of native git support
built right into it
collab Enterprise on the other hand is
kind of designed to be more of a zero
config serverless experience it's very
focused on collaboration it's excellent
for users who don't want to manage or
worry about compute at all they just
want to hit go and start typing and run
their code it's great for projects that
can be encapsulated in a single notebook
and it's good for users who don't want
to worry about git where that built-in
versioning is going to help them keep
track of their work and avoid data loss
without having to do and do a bunch of
git commands
so that's how we think about both of
these products and and how they live in
the market and the types of uses they
might be uh applicable towards
so
going with the theme of vertex is now
kind of one large platform where we're
trying to take you all the way through
the ml journey I want to use the next
demo in the next few minutes to talk
about how you could fine-tune a
foundation model using our SDK from
within collab Enterprise
uh how many people out of curiosity are
thinking about fun fine-tuning
Foundation models gen AI models okay so
good amount if I think about it multiple
times a day absolutely that's great
that's great
um so uh in that sense this is this is
probably how a lot of ml is going to be
done in the future you're probably not
going to start with nothing you're going
to start with one of these Foundation
models you're going to take your
company's data your data or data
specific to the problem you're trying to
solve fine tune and that's going to be
how you get really performant thing so
this is a really important use case and
we want to make sure that we make it as
simple as possible so if we could flip
back to the demo computer
I'll go ahead and show you
how simple we do make it
okay so I'm going to go ahead and pop
into model Garden again in the the theme
of showing you how we're trying to make
sure everything comes together and
doesn't feel as like a bunch of
Individual Services but one cohesive
platform
you can pick any of the existing
Foundation models or any of the
fine-tunable models that we have from
various sources and if you click on them
you will often get a link that says open
notebook and what this does is it will
open a notebook in Co-op Enterprise that
gives you instructions how to work with
that particular model and then you could
execute that particular notebook
now I've actually made a slightly
simplified version that shows you how to
tune text lesson as I have labeled it so
hopefully demo three
I think what I really want to just
emphasize is like how
simple this is
so
first thing I'm going to do is I want to
do some setup I'm going to you know put
in my project ID regions Define the
service account that can be used and
then from within the SDK I just say hey
I need to pull the list of text
generation models right and then I'm
going to pull from the pretend set and I
give it the name of the pre-trained
model that I want to work with in this
case text bison
and then you know you can immediately
test and see if it works right you can
do model.predict give it a prompt and
it'll give you back
a response there
now
to tune the model it's literally this
block of code right here
model.tune model you give it your
training data you specify some
parameters and then you specify where
you want the job to run
and then you click on play now what
happens when this happens this actually
creates a Vertex pipeline job and I'm
going to go ahead and click over so you
can see that pipeline job in action for
a second
so for those who aren't familiar with
vertex pipelines this is a machine
Learning orchestration System it's built
on top of cube flow pipelines and what
you're seeing here is a pipeline that
actually goes through and does all the
things necessary to tune a model using a
fairly efficient algorithm
for doing that
um
and then once it's done tuning the model
it actually goes ahead and it deploys
that model to an endpoint so you can
start testing it
this pipeline takes a little while to
execute about 30 to 40 minutes or so so
I'm going to actually go ahead and show
you when that's done by clicking on this
view alternate tuning jobs button
I do have to pick the right
region and you can see I've been I've
been doing this a lot I've been
practicing my demo quite often
um
so I'm going to pick one that I've
already got set up here and I'm going to
actually click on the test button here
and what you can see is that that
immediately takes me to
um
to The Prompt Library here but you can
go ahead and ask it you know you can
provide prompts and test it so I can say
hey tell me the best things
about vertex AI
and um
it should give me back hopefully a nice
nice set of things about vertex Ai No
Simplicity power flexibility security
these are all things we want to talk
about
and literally that's that's all that you
had to do to tune this model that that
model does live in the model registry
that we talked about earlier
um you can see it here you can see it's
been deployed you can look at the
endpoints you can kind of do whatever
you want to do from this from this point
here
now uh
sorry support the U.S Central one to
show you that
this model was trained in in the
Netherlands but uh deployed in Iowa so
it's it's quite a global model
as you can see
so with that said
um let's say I want to now evaluate a
model and the question now becomes how
do I do that I'm going to go ahead and
flip back to collab Enterprise for a
second and I want to show you the code
sample that actually does that
and it's equivalently straightforward
there isn't a lot more that you have to
do here it's simply you get the tune
model that you just tuned and you have
to provide the identifier to it and then
you actually provide your ground truth
data
picking a particular task you need to do
model.evaluate
and again this spins up a Vertex
pipeline that you can go take a look at
and then in the model registry
all of these results are
registered and you can kind of see how
they compare to each other if you're
doing multiple runs on multiple versions
for example this particular model I've
been training and tuning in a couple of
different ways and um
evaluating with a few different sets so
I can go ahead and see oops I don't want
to do that I can go ahead and see the
different metrics from the different
runs I've done and how they compare up
against each other
and so again the point we're trying to
make here I think is that we've tried to
bring this all together into one
cohesive platform we have an SDK that
makes it very easy for you to execute
this Foundation model tuning eval
process so if we can flip back to the
slides
so
let's just go ahead and
okay so the just a recap here is you
know you pull that we pulled that
Foundation model we've initiated a
tuning job in an vertex pipelines it
generated some adapter layers uh and
then the model was registered with model
registry
uh it then
serve that model in a pretty efficient
way
applying the new adapter layers uh and
then you could call that model and test
it and see what happened so that is the
entirety of the workflow it took maybe
you know less than 20 lines of code to
execute and do so very very
straightforward everything's built on
top of vertex pipelines technology that
many issue already used and are familiar
with
and um
so overall I think we're making a lot of
good progress of making some of these
key workflows very very simple for you
um I'm just going to close out here I
hope to have a little bit more time for
questions but it looks like we won't
have that by saying uh collab Enterprise
is in public preview today it's
available via the vertex UI if you go
look at it if you want to access it by a
bigquery studio it is behind an allow
list please contact your account
representatives and they'll help you get
on that and the code generation feature
is also behind and allow this so if you
want to access that let us know and
we'll get you on there as well so thank
you everyone for your time on the um
afternoon of the second day and I hope
those of you have happy hours to get to
I'm not standing a new way or anything
else so thank you and have a good day
[Applause]
[Music]